My next question was, well, okay, so people aren't
very good at guessing their audience sizes. But maybe,
maybe people who are older, maybe they have a
better sense, than teenagers, for example. So the next
plot that we did was another scatter plot, but
this time we added a third level, where we
added color to represent the age of the survey
respondent. And you can see again we have this horizontal
stripes for people who are guessing that there are 50
or 100 people in their audience. But I don't see
any pattern in the color. I think this is actually
kind of a dead end. This is one example of
kind of a failure. I can tell if younger people
were more accurate then older people, there is too much
over plotting. In this plot there are too many dots
on top of each other and color really doesn't add much.